let's talk about what was the Hanseatic
GUI I got this question when I published
my first video about Berlin and I
promised I would answer it in one of my
future videos and here we are one year
later so the Hanseatic League in
layman's terms was a trade agreement of
the northern European Baltic trading
cities however it's not that simple to
go all the way to the start of the
Hanseatic League we have to talk about
the Vikings and no I'm not talking about
the lovey-dovey Vikings that came to an
area so women were beautiful
the land was prosperous and decided to
stay now I'm talking about the good old
Vikings that raided and pillaged the
cities in a trading of the Baltic and
the northern seas this is you would
imagine made the northern trade routes
very impoverished and insignificant for
trade however the Viking raids stopped
around the middle of the 11th century
and the trade in the northern Baltic Sea
started to pick up would this increase
wealth in the area the first to take
advantage of this was German merchants
who started to migrate along the baltic
and northern seas establishing small
gilt
and trading towns so these trading towns
still exist to this day like this being
gulf length or Riga in Latvia or even
Berlin the formation of gilt during the
11th and 12th century was nothing new in
Western Europe as various gilt started
to pop up all around medieval Europe the
guilds want to protect the blacksmith's
or jewelers or barrel makers by creating
Common Market through setting of minimum
prices and certain production standards
for the product the guild made the early
German trade guilds and this Baltic
towns just the same however not with
products but with trade markets and
tariffs it wasn't until the half that
illegal those still not officially code
that has a degree at this point started
to form in Lubec during the 13th century
that the guild started to form into a
much larger league encompassing wider
areas of the baltic and german trading
towns with this ever enlarging league of
trading gilts many more towns there are
the northern and Baltic seas started to
be settled by mostly German merchants in
the simplest terms how the settlement
worked and already established talents
is that merchants will show up and after
examining the trading value of the goods
in the area and the viability of trade
routes from the main city in the area
they would decide whether to form a sort
of settlement or not if they did they
would try to get permission from the
local ruler to set up merchant
settlement outside of the city walls
although on some occasion also inside
the local rules usually agree to
as they knew that the merchant guilds
could bring a lot of revenue to the area
which was very true a city like Danzig
and Novgorod became influential trading
hubs exactly because of these trading
posts after the setup of these guild
settlements and various trading cities
or towns never-ending battle between the
gilts and the rulers ensued with guilds
always trying to get more privileges and
lower taxes and rulers always trying to
resist it this is one of the reasons why
the Hanseatic League fund in the first
place is to protect and promote the
privileges of guild merchants with the
local rulers in the various trade posts
and create a sort of early Schengen area
of free trade for the merchant cities
the formation of the Hanseatic League
itself is usually credited to the
emergence of Lubich as a trading hub for
the outgoing and angling shipping in the
Baltic Sea and also its control of much
of the fishing in the area later in the
13th century Lubich formed a partnership
with first Hamburg and then cologne
Lunenburg etc and this league managed to
get some very lucrative trading
privileges in the HRE and also London
even though we could call this league
the Hanseatic League at this point it
wasn't technically officially called the
Hanseatic League before the Year 1356
Hyundai League League during the next
three centuries dominated the trade in
Northern Europe fighting numerous trade
posts and inaugurating into its ranks
many new towns cities merchants
the Hanseatic League charged taxes
levied armies protected cities and held
meetings with all its members to a
certain extent you could say it acted
like its own country formed by only
trading posts and cities along the north
and the Baltic seas all Hanseatic League
merchants we're living in Britain
Scandinavia or Russia abide by German
laws and we're largely exempt from many
of the taxes that on the people in those
areas it's important to understand that
they had ethically continuing into the
14th and 15th century was a League of
merchants guilt around northern Europe
and even though the hazard elite was
very much so unique it still was just as
any other trade league set up on very
complicated trade agreements between
each guilds training hub kingdom duchy h
re free city and way too much
complicated economic history we don't
have time to get into every tax
exemption Trade Agreement German law etc
has a ton of asterisks attached next to
them because it's all varied between
cities kingdoms and training hubs and
was all
governed by the Hanseatic League empathy
how deadly started to fall into decline
around the sixteenth century as the
emergence of the Swedish Empire and
Prussia in the area started to take
control of the trade in the Baltic Sea
plus the emergence of nationalism
created shifting goals for cities in the
Hanseatic League and many cities start
to put the issues of their state before
the league what is hit to the league
however with the emergence of
state-sponsored trading companies that
form during the excavation age and the
heightening power of the Dutch and
British merchants in the Baltic Sea
slowly many of the cities left the
Hanseatic League and the only ones that
stayed all the way till the German
reunification in 1862 were Lubich
Hamburg and Bremen and that's where I
will conclude talking about the
Hanseatic League I hope that wasn't too
confusing to understand as I had to
gross over a lot of things but honestly
the Hanseatic League just on its own is
very complicated and that's why it is
still studied today by economists to
understand how it worked and maybe use
what they learned in today's modern
markets
[Music]
you
[Music]